this guy knows all about the Final Four
he's Rick Pitino who took the job at
Iona but before we talked to you Rick I
got to bring you back to last September
when you were on the program and you had
this to say do you think you coach again
no I you know I wrote this book for
closure because I don't think I'll have
a coach again and I wanted the truth to
come out in a lot of different things
I'm I don't think any University is
going to hire me and I wouldn't want
that I wouldn't want them to go through
it would you hire you know yes what's in
this book is the truth like you wouldn't
believe
would you coach in the NBA I'm done
coaching I really am because the Nets
called you know III think the NBA is a
grind it's a hundred game assume it
again and although I'm in great shape
it's a grind and I I don't want to coach
I miss college terribly it's a big part
of my life but I've got to learn to live
without it and because I know I'm not
gonna coach again so what changed coach
well I think I think I was and
rightfully so I was blackballed
incorrectly for two and a half years do
the Southern District of New York coming
out and putting me in a in a complaint
and then actually two and a half years
later they exonerated me by putting
people on the witness stand who got up
from adidas representatives to the
father of the recruit saying I
absolutely knew nothing about it
and it took two and a half years for
that to go to trial before I could be
exonerated that's one thing the second
thing is I only think sort of was a
lucky thing in a play of the genesis of
it when I left Louisville my business
partner was good friends with the
president of Transylvania and I left him
and his wife tickets for a few
Louisville games he's a basketball fan
and he called me up and said coach would
you like me to call there were two
schools high-powered schools that were
somebody interested in me would you like
me to call the president's I know what
you're all about and that'd be one happy
to do so and I said boy that's real nice
of you
probably not going to matter too much
but thank you so much and he did call
one of the two well that person moved on
and became the iona president and he
called my friend said is there any way I
was over in Greece and is there any way
that your friend would consider coaching
at Iona we may have a move here because
our coach has been sick and we feel
awful about it he's meant so much to us
school and would he be interested so I
think it's circumstance more than
anything else I think it took two and a
half years to get exonerated and I am I
can't tell you how happy I am I'm beyond
happy because it's it's going home it's
25 minutes from my apartment in New York
City it's ten minutes from my son in
Harrison New York so for me it's a dream
come true it's a it's a great way to end
a career and I can't tell you how
excited I am
were you up for the st. John's job I was
not oh but did you inquire about that I
did not okay because I there were
published reports that said that you you
were trying to get the st. John's job a
while ago so no I I was I was actually
interested in three jobs where I thought
I had a legitimate shot one was because
Michigan was wooing and coolly from
Providence I would have loved to come
back to a school I love dearly but he
stated Providence the other one was a
small Catholic school list of
Massachusetts Holy Cross had an opening
and I knew a lot of the alumni and
people on the board there I was looking
for a smaller situation that aspired to
be much better than where they were at
and I was looking for a Catholic school
and this turned out to be even more
perfect and Holy Cross because it was
it's it's 25 minutes from where I live I
also was thinking about this knowing
that we were going to have you on you
were ahead of the curve before you know
almost everybody with the the weapon
that the three-point shot was going to
be back at Providence you had guys like
you guys got green lights you know Billy
Donovan you
shoot the three what was it about the
three that you understood before most
college and pro coaches did the
fascinating thing about it is I think it
was the first five Big East games
against John Thompson Lily left Cimino
think it was PJ the most any of the
movie caught a second the most any of
those schools took at a game with five
threes I think they made one or two in
all five games and I was trying to take
18 to 25 degrees I took over a team that
really lost all that players and they
were dead last in the Big East since the
inception of the Big East seven straight
years and I not only needed a weapon I
need a gimmick I need something that
would overcome our lack of athleticism
and the three-point shot was it we
worked at it we worked at it from an out
of bounds situation fast-break situation
steal situation everything we built was
around the three-point line we led the
nation in three-point shooting and that
was the key to going to a final floor
and just pure Matt what it's become
today you understand it and even with
the New York Knicks we were known as the
bumbino's and we were averaging almost
118 points a game and the three-point
shot was a big weapon for us was Paul
Westhead the like the Godfather of the
three-point shot or was no he was he was
the Godfather a fast-break basketball
scoring he was basically if he was a
football coach he would let the other
team score so he could get the ball back
so he was the kid
The Godfather a fast break the mum bed
fast break it wasn't so much the
three-point line as it was the fast
break he believed in a style that would
give you a hundred fifteen hundred
twenty points a game yeah it was so much
fun but you know I remember that
Providence team and it and it looked
like a lineup that I could have played
in you know just you you gave that
feeling of hey this is all I got and
we're gonna go out there but look you
every place you've gone you know you're
successful and you know you just want a
championship in Greece and I expect you
to be you know successful at Iona the
expectation level that you have
on you and your team is what well I own
is coming off a difficult year because
they lost a tremendous coach Tim Cruz
has done a fabulous job there and one of
the other reasons down I took the job is
Dick Baikal said something's amazing you
know you know how close I was to Jimmy
Bay and you knew him well he said Jim
Valvano always told him his favorite
years were Iona College and that stuck
out with me because my two favorite
years in coaching with Providence
College and Iona right now is down
because they lost a great coach who got
sick and they went from fourth straight
MCAS out of five years to having a
losing a year and the rosters depleted
so right now we've got to bring in
probably six to seven players we've got
to enhance the schedule but the school
itself the president is the reason I
went there the athletic director is an
outstanding ad and the school I'm
friendly with the person who the
business school is named after Bob
LaPenta is a good friend of mine the
chairman of the board I know quite well
so it's it's they have huge aspirations
to not only make the basketball program
much bigger but to grow to school and
they think the basketball program is a
vehicle to help grow to school as well
from the endowment to the enrollment and
the more exposure the basketball program
gets in a positive way the more the
school will rise are you going to
schedule Louisville no I'm a schedule
I'm a schedule John I spoke to her Kali
yesterday was nice enough to call me but
I I would love to schedule Kentucky in
the garden in the Jimmy D Classic I
think that would be a great drawer and
that would be exciting to see and I hope
John would entertain that why don't you
have Louisville Kentucky and Providence
we have Kentucky Providence is good to
talk to your coach and glad you're back
in college basketball and we'll be in
thanks Dan I'm super excited that's rick
pitino